this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm john dolone joined
here with my good friend and
best-selling author
mrs rachel cruz and we are here to talk
to you about what's going on in your
life
give us a shout at 825-5225
money relationships challenges
whatever's going on give us a shout
rachel how are we doing
doing great yeah it's gonna be yeah good
show john we did an hour yesterday
we made it barely three hours today
we're barely surprised
oh that's so good oh it's so fun and i'm
excited about tonight our money and
marriage event
is gonna be really fun we just finished
the final block in here a little bit
it's going to be a blast yeah yeah
it's great can we awesome um before we
go i have to just make this public
announcement
i was wrong when i bet
our engineer here that the buccaneers
were going to lose
to my patrick mahomes ah
i lost kyle gotcha kyle won i was
incorrect
and i felt it appropriate too he's
reminding me every day
how wrong i was he's that guy that's
still wearing bucks gear here we are
like seven days later or whatever [ __ ] a
little sport in the hat kyle some of us
would say
just let it go but i know that's the
attitude of a loser so way to go kyle
you won i was wrong all right let's go
to josiah in salt lake city
josiah what's going on how can we help
hey dr d and rachel
thanks for taking my call to keep a long
story short um
for for a little bit now i've had some
suspicion that my brother was stealing
money through
uh various sources from my disabled
mother
i confronted him about it and let my
mother know what was going on
he still has not been 100 honest with
either me or my mother
um my issue is this isn't a first time
saying he's stolen from me before
i'm just finding it hard to keep a
relationship with both my brother and my
mom because
now um she's she's looking at as
if it's a minor issue um and i'm worried
that it's just gonna bleed or dry and
eventually he's just gonna
be gone and i'm gonna be stuck trying to
fund
her for the rest of her life yeah
you man i hate this for you josiah
you're wrestling with
um i can hear as you're processing this
you're turning in this
into a future math problem but man i
want to bring you back to right here
this just hurts man and i hate that for
you what's
what struggles does your mom have um
she's
since i was 10 so about 20 years ago she
was diagnosed
with art she's now just got multiple
other
health issues um she's she's basically
been
bedridden my whole life that's hard man
so here's a challenge that everybody
with this type of family situation deals
with we all are
we love our brothers and sisters our
moms and dads we are all trained to
um and socialized and it's just the
right thing i mean you you take care of
your family right you default to that
and unfortunately there's these moments
like you're experiencing when
your brother is still your brother but
he also becomes that grown man that's
hurting mom
right and at some point you have to lean
into that
and do hard things which like call the
police
and if your brother's stealing from your
mom and you've got proof of it
and your mom is not in a position to
take care of yourself then that's the
logical responsibility it's hard and it
feels like you're violating that family
what i'll tell you it's it's a phrase i
use all the time but it's not by your
hand but it's in your lap
right you didn't cause this you're not
going to be the you're not going to be
the result
you're not going to be the person who
who broke up the family your brother
is making some really reckless um wrong
decisions taking advantage of your mom
and now it's your situation to
to to deal with right because your
brother's not acting with character
right
and josiah does he have does he still
have the ability
to steal from your mom like is it
accounts numbers that he has
yeah so i i actually kind of put the
kibosh on that um
she she because she was so dependent on
me and him she had her he had her debit
card and
so i i forced him to give it back to her
and i told her that because now they
have that information that she needs to
change her her card number and
everything immediately yeah
yeah yeah so i think it's i think that's
the right thing to do brother and
i think you're it's just one of those
moments where you find yourself in a
hard position you didn't cause this you
didn't
it's not not your fault but now you're
the person
who's going to be responsible be the
person of integrity that's going to have
to turn and deal with it and so that
means getting the authorities involved
if your brother
is going to continue to kind of be the
person that steals from your mom
i hate that terrible and then josiah too
i mean i know i think
focusing on the present is extremely
important right now but also to know
long term like
it probably is going to be you taking
care of your mom i mean if she's if she
is bedridden and she doesn't have
a way to make an income then she is
going to
need to eat right i mean like and your
brother is obviously
not a dependable trustworthy person so i
would go ahead and emotionally
say okay what can i do to help my mom in
the future because it probably is going
to be you josiah so i'd be thinking
about that as well
and those are those are we just talk to
millions of people who are
faced with those situations mom and dad
don't want to sign over
you know accounts or they won't can't
join accounts and i'm just trying to do
the math what my future might look like
and sometimes it's
there is no easy answer to that right
right but there's a responsible answer
you can
pretend it's not going to happen or you
could pretend yeah this is probably
going to be us
you your future spouse you know we've
got to start planning for this
financially
what does that look like yeah oh man uh
let's go to calvin in st
george utah calvin what's going on man
how can we help
hi a pleasure to be on the show a big
fan
i've been listening for a long time um
so i was recently accepted into dental
school
and uh the cost of dental school is
really high as you may be away
yes and my first place may be in excess
of 400 000
in debt um to go to dental school
um i applied to the military scholarship
because i am such a big fan of dave
ramsey's show and
i'm kind of living debt i applied for
military scholarship
uh they will completely pay for the
schooling um but i owe them
year for year of the school so it's a
four-year commitment to them
um my question is is it worth the
opportunity cost
i could potentially get out of dental
school and be making
much more than what the military would
pay me and potentially pay it off
in four to
six years and living under my knees
or should i take the military
scholarship that they'll cover and then
have that commitment to them and it's
just kind of what would you recommend
on that what do you want to do do you
want to go to the military
uh yes i i do have interest in the
military
why do you want to go to the military
what is it about the military that
excites you
service to country i am interested in
and um
i do stand for a lot of the same values
they have okay
so i i would i would back up and rachel
i'd love you to hop in here i'd back up
and
you're not not going to dental school
you're not going to take up 400 thousand
dollars or half a million dollars with
the loans
because you like dave ramsey you're not
going to take a half million dollars
worth of loans because that's half a
million dollars worth of loans
and you never know when a pandemic's
going to come through and say they're
going to close your dental practice for
a year and you're going to be up a creek
and on top of that you're a guy who
wants to serve in the military
and the military has this incredible
program that's going to pay for it for
you
and so if those two interests align i
wouldn't tell you to go to the military
if you were just trying to scam the
system so they'll pay for something
but if you are about service which you
are you love their values which you are
i think that's commendable and
extraordinary
man let them pay for your dental school
you're going to serve all of our
absolutely you're going to learn by
serving our soldiers and our military
and then you're going to be able to come
make a great difference in your local
community brother
i love your heart that's what i would do
man this is the ramsay show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local
communities whether your goals are to
get an education
serve your country or have a better life
the army national guard can help you get
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the ramsey
show and i'm john deloney joined here
with rachel cruz and we are taking your
calls on money
taking your calls on life
relationships are hard right now money
is tight things are just
hard give us a shout let's go to nathan
in atlanta
georgia nathan what's going on how are
we doing hey thank you for taking my
call
you bet brother what's going on all
right so
uh i'm 26 years old i mean i'm 24 years
old i'm married to my
wife she's 23 years old and we have 62
000
in debt and we make 72 000 combined
and in may we're about to lose her
income for a while because she
is going to move into uh real estate and
be a real estate agent
okay um two of those loans to
part of that debt is collection so our
credit scores
are pretty much non-existent they're
really bad
and we have two cars and uh one car has
sixteen thousand dollars owed on it and
her car has uh
thirty six thousand dollars owed on it
okay so
we can't go to a credit agency and you
know get a
loan for the depreciation on her car
however i can sell mine i have a
thousand dollars equity in it
but we're just i'm just kind of
wondering where i go from here because
we we started the 14-day trial of ramsey
plus and we've been doing the financial
keys
university stuff but just kind of
overwhelmed a little bit right now
yeah for sure uh so the 36 000 car how
much is it worth now
it's uh worth twenty nine thousand
twenty nine i only bought it like
six months ago and
have you talked to a local credit union
nathan
yeah they're outside of atlanta of a
couple have you sat down with them and
shown them
showing them the numbers i mean like you
have all the paperwork you're talking to
them
did you do it yes we went to our local
one called connecticut credit union yeah
that's where we actually bank at and we
showed them everything and uh
we just don't have the credit to do
anything about it i mean i'm looking at
our
with our debt con you know getting this
debt paid off
i can probably do it in four years uh
with just my income but and hopefully
she can start selling some houses but i
know that when you go into real estate
it's a while before you actually collect
it yeah what is she doing what is she
doing now nathan
she's captioning phone calls for people
that are hard of hearing
okay and how much does she make in that
she only makes about 26 000.
26. okay so she'll i mean yeah real
estate it takes a little bit but you're
in a hot market so hopefully she's going
to be making more commissions than 26
000. i was about to say depending on how
much percentage of her income
for her to just stay in that job for
another year or two just to be bringing
in a steady income to be able for you
guys to pay off this debt
but she's only making 26 so i'm like no
she she can make more doing real estate
could she do both rachel uh
yeah she could do both is that possible
nathan that real estate while
you know you're grinding it out you're
doing those things can she do both for a
season it's going to be a busy hard
season it just feels like a really an
opportune time to lose
half your income uh the issue with that
is the company she works for it doesn't
give you an option on your scheduling
and uh she has talked to them about
possibly going part-time but
even then her schedule would be so
whacked and it's
it's not a set schedule like you know
what you're going to be working they
change it every week
and she wouldn't be able to keep
appointments and stuff like that she's
going to have to leave that job
okay okay so nathan let me get a little
bit more um
tactical your the debts you got you have
the two car payments and then what else
do you have
i've got the two car payments we've got
a 1200
credit card okay we've got a 4 500
credit card that we bought furniture
with okay
and i've got 4 500 in collections my
wife has a 2600
student loan and she has a 900
collection that's a medical bill
okay okay
so the the the positive thing here is
that
besides that 36 dollar car and you're
sixteen thousand i'd sell your sixteen
thousand go ahead and get a thousand
dollar car go ahead and just get that
out of the way because that's going to
give you just like a
oh a breath of fresh air of not having
that 16 grand
i would go talk to two more credit
unions to see if there's anything they
can do to get a loan for the difference
to get rid of that 36 000.
you may be just stuck with it which i
hate to say it but that might be the
case
and then for you guys i mean nathan
you're gonna it's gonna be a level of
intensity and sacrifice
for you and your wife for probably
a good 24 months and the more
you guys can bring in in the income side
and we're just saying maybe she maybe
she stays at that 26 000 job to your
point john
and starts selling houses at night when
people are off work doing
open houses on sundays doing stuff on
saturdays
but just going full-fledged because
there's a lot of these little like 900
1200 if you guys buckle down you do a
tight budget you can start knocking some
of this stuff out
and that's the beauty i love about the
debt snowballs like you're you're it's
all these numbers
and besides the big car payments it's
these little ankle biters and i'm like
man you can just put so much intensity
and start knocking those out
but you guys have to be working together
in this
and there's going to be extra work on
the side yeah i would i nathan if
if that's me and i have a dream of being
a real estate agent but i find myself in
your situation
i'm going to have a hard take a hard
look at take weight in a year
waiting two years and maybe doing this
job and getting the nighttime gig
driving
or clawing and scratching whatever you
guys got to do
this feels like an emergency and it also
feels like
something that's solvable but you may
have to hold off on the dream part until
you get some of this
the math part that's really against you
um here's the thing this is going to be
hard on your
marriage so i want to make sure y'all
are connected we're going to start you
off right so i want you to hang on and
kelly is going to give you guys a free
ticket to tonight's live stream with me
and rachel as soon as the show's over
we're gonna
head out to the to the tv studios here
tonight at 7 p.m
we have the marriage and money event you
can go to daveramsey.com
events for tickets it's going to be
hilarious it's going to be fun
we're also going to tell you the truth
about your marriage your money how y'all
can come together
about intimacy all these things that
folks are wrestling with and nathan we
want to give you guys this gift to start
you guys off on this journey you guys
got to hang in there with each other
running hard and fast for 24 long months
all right let's go to tony
in norfolk virginia tony what's going on
man how can we help
hi how are you doing good good good okay
so let me keep it as brief as possible
i am a high school spanish teacher and
my salary is
in the upper 40s that's uh my contracted
salary
and i had 15 000 of student loan debt
back from college that i i paid some of
it off it was higher than that it's now
down to 15 000.
wife's a homemaker we have kids now just
so you know
i bought my house before i knew about
dave ramsey so don't get mad at me no
we're not we're not man
yeah but i have i have baby stuff one
already done with and uh this house that
i bought is actually an
older house and i did that to sort of
keep the price low but there are
things that need to be repaired around
here and so i have a tax return coming
in
and what my wife and i were discussing
and you just want to sort of get you
guys advice about it
should i throw my whole tax return at
the student loans
or should i hold back a significant
chunk of it
in case some sort of repair pops up
around here
how how much is the refund going to be
in the neighborhood of six grand
of six thousand and what kind of repairs
what kind of repairs are you think are
you just saying like
it's okay cosmetic or is it for example
it's an older house that's on a well
it's you know serve out in sticks
and uh the uh water needs treatment to
make it
fully potable like you know it's because
we've been buying water and drinking
that rag and drinking what comes out as
well because it needs a water softener
system installed and all those kinds of
things yeah
but you guys i mean you can you can have
water
bottled water or whatever right i mean
like you're not dependent on that wet is
that well
i mean is it i'm on a wheel and i i got
you tony yeah if that well goes out that
will goes out right then there's no
there's no toilets showers nothing
exactly
but my i guess yes but i'm asking like
the urgency of it like is it
do you is it is it you don't know when
it's gonna go out is it that oh yeah i
know when we bought the house they said
we have three months like
no it's it's it's still it's still it's
still working now the problem is the
water needs to be softened and
conditioned because it's eroding our
pipes basically
like the acidity and things like that
and the water need to actually be
treated because that could lead to other
plumbing problems
okay well yeah i mean your
your food and water when you have your
basics that you need to be covered now a
water softener
looking at what that costs if that's
something that you absolutely need to do
i just want you to get caught up in this
house and it keeps sucking down your
money and your student loans hanging
around so it's a prior
it's a prioritization that you're going
to have to do so if the question is
ultimately yeah
should we add a couple more thousand
bucks just to be safe what i don't want
you to do is pull that and feel like
we're gonna start remodeling we're gonna
start upgrading
right you're still in this debt
emergency yeah but if you know you've
got a big thing hanging over you
i don't have a problem with you putting
that aside if you know what's going to
happen it's happening if you get to the
end of this year and you need to pay it
off
then you can just dump that money onto
that student loan but let's get that
sucker paid off and thanks for being a
teacher during this madness what a saint
[Music]
[Applause]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash
budget we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey
show i'm dr john deloney joined with my
good friend best-selling author
host of the world famous rachel cruz
show the world famous
rachel cruz you know one thing we do
well here what we spend a lot of
creative energy
time on our on our titles titling tv
shows and podcasts good grief rachel
cruz show the john delany show
there's just so many meetings about it
just like wow
so many right so crazy and this is
unveiling we've got it guys here it is
all right let's go to matt in uh
cleveland matt what's going on man
hey john hey rachel hey what's up how
can we help
hey um so i have a question um i'm
starting to
feel a lot of kind of resentment or
frustration towards some of my friends
who are being financially irresponsible
like they'll be going on vacations when
i know that you're like
either they'll complain about money
issues or things of that issue or they
won't have jobs
i know dave shout dave says to share
your journey but that doesn't seem to
work
um listening to the show all the time
i feel like financially winning is what
dave teaches
and so i mean i'm kind of out of i feel
like i'm the crazy one sometimes but
listening to your show i feel like the
normal one i don't know
um so how can i stop the feelings that i
have of
not everyone wins um
so whenever i hear the word resentment
the word resentment
or resentment in general is the absolute
death bell
of a relationship whenever you cross
that line to
like i'm frustrated with you that means
you're in a good relationship
i'm annoyed i'm angry with you that
means you're in a good relationship that
means there's things about this that you
care about
when you get to the resentment part it's
an ash
right it's hard and when we talk to
folks whose marriage when they resent
their per
their partner man that's hard to come
back from my first question to you
is it feels like you have an air of
superiority around your friends that i'd
want to challenge you on
that you you handle money differently
than they do there you feel like they're
being irresponsible
there's a gap between um friends like
hey i don't make that decision i'll make
that decision
yours feels a little bit higher than
that do you feel like you're better than
them walk me through where your head's
at man
um it's it's more just when they're
going on vacations but um
but i mean the next day they'll complain
about their problems i'm like come on
like if you didn't take that vacation
like
you'd have the money to do you know to
pay your car rent
i mean carly's so rachel i'd love to get
your thoughts i
i have something with my buddies with my
longtime friends
which is when they ask for my opinion
i'll give it to them yeah and if they
don't
i am in such a tight relationship with
them that i feel free to mock their
choices and we do it in good fun because
we love each other right
um but i don't hold the outcome i just
am committed to sitting with them
when things are challenging right so
when they call me and they say
i went on a vacation i didn't now i
can't make rent
i get to say well duh right
but i'm not going to hold it's not my
fault that they made that decision right
that's right i'm not going to hold that
because yeah there's a level of of
responsibility matt i feel like you're
taking on for your friends and that's
what's like stirring up all these
emotions
and so being able to see my counselor
did this about a different relationship
in my life
but i wish you could see me but he like
had these scissors and he was like
pretending to cut these like strings
he's like
cut the strings yeah cut the strings
you're not emotionally responsible for
this so matt you're not respond you're
not responsible for their choices
and yeah if they're just complaining all
the time then you can say hey are you
good if i just kind of share where i'm
at
what what i see and in a loving way just
like yeah i mean
if that cost two grand and your rent 600
you know 1200 yeah you could have used
it i mean i don't know it's just math
and
but it's not emotional because you're
you're not responsible for them that's
right
matt can i ask you one other question
it's gonna sound like i'm coming after
you but i just want to get to
a little bit deeper is there a part of
you that wishes you were going on these
vacations with them
part of me wishes i could go on the
vacation um part of me
yeah part of me does wish i could go on
those vacations with them
so that's a big moment man and it's okay
to be frustrated that the the choices
you're choosing to make in your life
are cutting out on some fun right now
that the choices you are choosing right
now
are annoying right they are keeping you
from
you know firecrackers and whatever i get
that dude and it sucks
the moment you can say i'm frustrated
and
you can pause and say am i frustrated
just because i want to be going on a
vacation
but i'm sticking to this budget for the
time being because i'm playing a long
game with my life
or am i frustrated because i love my
friends and they're making ding-dong
choices
or am i just a grumpy guy right if you
find that
i'm just frustrated that i don't get to
go then you can circle back to i'm
making a series of choices because i'm
i'm investing in my future i'm investing
in my family i don't even have yet i'm
investing in
filling all these things i want to be
able to help my neighbor in any way
shape form or fashion
man then you've got a frustration's okay
right
yeah it's just part of the process and
like rachel said you don't own
their outcome yeah right divorce
yourself and i think one of the hardest
things when it comes
and probably anything in life but
specifically money with people in your
life so whether it's parents
spouse for well no i wouldn't count
spouses but friends
uh parents in-laws right i mean
all these people in your life and when
they make different choices than you
make
and you hear the complaining and all of
that i mean that that's a very very real
thing
and understanding that until they ask
your opinion yeah
just keep it to yourself yeah or like
you said matt already like share your
story share
where you're at if you long for that but
that is a hard thing
for people because there's a level of
control we want to have for the people
that we love because you do see them
harming themselves you're like dang it
dang it
but listen they're grown-ups and they
get to make their decisions and my
guests matt is if you sat down with them
they'd say
man matt when you're not around we all
talk about you we want you just to have
some more fun
and smile and so what if we figured out
ways to do some things together that
maybe didn't involve this
you're not late on any of your bills
yeah exactly you pay your bills every
month so
thanks for that call matt and um next
time you get sideways
just pause for that that one moment and
say is this just cause i'm
jealous is this because i'm frustrated
or is this because i'm trying to hold on
to somebody else's outcome man and free
yourself from that i love that analogy
cut the strings that's good
all right let's go to amy in hartford
what's up amy how are we doing
hi there you guys i'm doing well how are
you today
good how can we help sure
so my husband and i have been married
for just over a year
um and we're actually looking to buy our
first
house and we were just wondering if we
couldn't run some numbers by you guys
and see what you all think about
um where we are with our numbers what we
can afford what we should be
looking for in a first house absolutely
yeah
let us know bring it on bring it rachel
no numbers
to the others i might get myself on
calculator in just a second but
[Laughter]
sure so um right now we have about
just under 38 000 in our savings
um we've managed to actually pay off all
of our debts
um so i can't that free spring my
husband's not here
he's at work it's my day off um so we've
got
probably about 25 000 worth of debts
that we've paid off so we're pretty good
at saving and
hitting it hard where it counts in
regards to debt
so he makes probably about 40 uh
45 000 a year i'm just under 30.
um but in the next maybe two months or
so he's going to be
going after a different job in which
he'll probably make about 70
000 so we should be bringing in just
under a hundred thousand
okay uh do you guys have any is that the
38 000 the only savings you have
correct yeah we've got a little buffer
in our checking it's just under 5 000.
yeah for sure
um okay well our rule of thumb when it
comes to buying a home
is that i want your payment to be no
more than 25
of your take-home pay i want you to be
able to put down
10 to 20 for a down payment
and that 25 take-home pay your mortgage
payment is on a 15-year fixed rate
so so doing that math so the 70 000 job
is that a guarantee it's happening and
he's waiting to transition or is he
hoping he has it
no it's guaranteed it's actually
family-owned business
so um he's going to be working with his
dad so it's already been talked about
and agreed upon this pay rate
okay awesome awesome so i would do all
your calculations off of a hundred
thousand dollar
income but that thirty eight thousand
though amy i want some of that to stay
as your emergency fund do not spend that
all in the down payments you guys have a
little ways to go to save it for that
down payment depending on what
house you wanna buy how much that's
gonna be but run those numbers that's
kind of the formula we use
and you guys are in an awesome position
no debt emergency funds it's pretty fun
just being newlyweds man that's super
cool what an ex that's an exciting place
to be amy that's awesome
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm john dolone
with my good friend rachel cruz and
we're taking your calls on
life money triple eight eight two five
five two two five
we have somebody in our lobby that wants
to ask a live
question he's got the headset on he's
standing on the debt free stage not
doing the debt free scream not yet but
he wants to ask us
a question in person where we have to
look each other in the eye which is kind
of funny andy this doesn't happen very
often
that's really cool so i can't i'm just
overwhelmed to be here today
well we're grateful that you're here so
what's going on man how can we help so i
pastor a church in southern illinois
we have about 400 people in attendance
right before kovitz started
we were about to pull the trigger on
building a new sanctuary
last year we did our first financial
peace university class at our church
this year we just started a new one last
week
and man we it's changed my wife myself
my wife's life
matt and nick you're here with us today
we've seen a variety of different
families in our church
just greatly changed by the program and
man it's just it's brought in a whole
new attitude but one of the things going
through it
is that we're looking to to borrow
around 2.2 million dollars to build a
new sanctuary
scripture says borrower is slave to the
lender your dave repeats that often
and so i thought do you guys think it's
hypocritical for a church who is
practicing the principles of financial
peace university in their personal lives
to go out and borrow money
in a church setting so before you answer
that
as somebody who used to meet with people
behind closed doors right on hard
conversations
you get a sense when somebody already
has an answer in their heart
as they're asking the question even
though he framed it and so
andy i feel really strongly that you
have
an answer yes walk us through where you
are and how you got there
okay well it goes a little further than
that even and so
um recently god's been doing a great
work in me just through this last year
and so the thought process is is that
number one the answer should be no we
shouldn't
we should practice what we preach and if
we tell you to do it in your personal
lives we should do in our church life
secondly the state of illinois is kind
of different right now and i don't want
to go too much into that
but one of the things that we've just
started at our church is to actually
help
families the the educational institution
illinois is not good
and so one of the reasons for starting
at fpu was to help our families live
within their means so they could help
afford christian education and so this
year our church started to adopt this
program to where we will partner with a
family for up to 50 percent
of biblical education and every one of
our to every one of our members yeah
just rolled that out wow
and so one of the thought processes is
we would rather
we would rather educate our children
than build a building but at the same
time we're literally out of room right
and so
it's one of these catch-22s but you know
it's hard to go borrow 2.2 million
dollars when you're telling your
families
man live within your means go into
biblical education
exactly and so it's a difficult
situation so i've got a really strong
visceral reaction to this question for a
couple different reasons but
i want to turn it over to the wiser
calmer one of us first what do you think
rachel
i mean you you answered it i mean my
yeah my answer is gonna be
it's consistent so whether it's a bid
someone's opening a business i
never tell them to take out a small
business loan for a church it's the same
way and
and what's difficult though i understand
it's the building constraints but i'll
tell you here at ramsey
we were in a building about 10 miles
north
of where we are right now and we were
outgrowing it and it was like man but
there wasn't cash there to
to buy something and so we could have
you know taken a loan out and
built something like this you know years
and years ago
but we rented out another space and we
rented out another space and we were in
five different buildings and it was so
inconvenient
it was not fun we had like a little
shuttle that went around and like oh it
was just it was it was not
it was not ideal but we move at the
speed of cash around here and we do that
because we really do believe the
borrower is slave to the lender and your
your whole paradigm shifts again whether
it's a church
whether it's a business whether it's
your personal life
when you owe someone money the way you
look at things and so
to be able to say man are we invested
into this program like what you guys are
doing is
what how creative and how amazing and
fun
of that education and just move at the
speed of cash
just save over time and it's going to be
uncomfortable it's not going to be fun
but also covid hello
you know i mean you couldn't meet for
for months probably you know so like it
it really
uh thank god for covid because if you
wouldn't go borrow
two points it literally helped 2.2
million and couldn't even use it
at that point so that was that maybe god
may have saved you right there
and for me it's it's it's that and i get
real personal with it
being i tell teenagers i've told
teenagers for years
when they were whining about their
parents this and that my parents this
and i'd always tell them if your parents
are paying for that car
they're paying for that fill in the
blank
they get to speak into it it's theirs
right and
anytime a church a business me
when i hitch myself to somebody else
they get to tell me what to do that's
just the rules right
right and i think sometimes um like i i
find myself speaking out about it's not
because i hate institutions i think
institutions actually do wonderful stuff
on broad big scales
but man when i owe somebody they get to
tell me what to do
and i there's a lot of yelling and
screaming these days
and people don't don't they forget that
man i hitch myself to that wagon
most most recently in my life i haven't
had a mortgage in a while right
i got one recently and i'm having
trouble sleeping
because i am now
in debt to the bank right and they get
to tell me
nope you're going to keep going to work
every day you're going to keep filling
the blank right right
and so i'm going to tell you i think a
remarkable conversation for a leader in
a church right now
is to stand up and say this is going to
be messy we're going to figure it out
but we're going to do the right thing
and we are not going to hitch our wagon
to
a state a bank a federal government or
whatever
and it's not is it gonna be inconvenient
yep are we gonna have to have 14
services and do all this weird whatever
yep right
um but i think it's the right thing to
do right and
i'm just grateful for your heart man oh
absolutely and i would say this too
as someone who attends a church when i
know because our church is debt-free
they paid off all of their building debt
about four years ago and it was
incredible
and so now i know when i tithe that it's
not going to bank of america
right you know it's not going to an
interest payment it's literally going to
a single mom
because we have a whole car's ministry
and it's buying single mom cards like
that's like
that's what it's like it's going or it's
going to my pastor right to help pay his
salary
the the church staff like i know where
my money's going
and as a as a someone who tithes and
gives i'll tell you the heart of your
congregation to have that conversation
with john just said
yeah that builds trust and honestly i
think that's a that's a beautiful
conversation just to say it out loud
i'm only putting one foot on a soapbox
here because i could get myself in
trouble
i wish every every church in america any
denomination
would have a hard look in the mirror and
say how much money are we paying to
the salaries of our local bankers that
could be going to feeding
the kids in our communities it could be
putting kids in schools that could be
helping single moms
we do a lot of bickering and yelling
about you know government intrusion and
social programs and we sure like new
shiny things in churches yeah that's
that's been the heart is that you know
especially with this this education
program is you know
churches right now we're losing seven to
one and so for every seven kids
in this generation we're only getting
one back in the next and my thought was
man if we build a building in 20 years
we cannot have people to put in it
that's right
if we don't start investing in our kids
now and the in the big heart is is that
you know you pay this much money each
month to uh for
brick and mortar you know when you can
invest man in in the
in the future of our kids coming up yeah
and we're not mad at brick and mortar no
not at all absolutely like it's it's a
great thing you got the space all of it
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i praise god yeah there's
something about being in this action yep
moving at the speed of cash so
i think you know it i mean even the way
you asked the question that was a great
call
i hope every single small business owner
i hope every single non-profit leader
hope every single pastor
in this country is listening this
conversation and listening to your heart
man
because the more money we pass out in
other people's salaries that could be
going to healing these communities
right we the only gap person to fill
that gap becomes the government
right that's the greatest one of the
biggest problems we have in society
today is the church isn't playing the
role of the church
right right america he said it not me
just kidding
amen so ben i appreciate your heart and
financial peace university we talk about
what could the people of god do for the
kingdom of god if they had no debt
and that's on an individual basis but we
say yeah you put the government out of
business right like
as believers if you didn't have your car
payments your credit cards your student
loans
and you were able to give outrageously
that is literally the movement that is
what changes
so we did our our finished university
class last year are giving one of almost
a hundred thousand dollars
amazing well thank appreciate you
man pay off your debts
and then give recklessly yep first hour
in the books my good friend rachel cruz
big thanks to kelly
and to james we'll see you just in a
[Music]
minute
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your
life and your money i am dr john dolone
joined here with best-selling author
and all-around good human being ms
rachel cruz
and we are taking your calls on life on
money whatever's going on in your heart
mind give us a shout triple eight eight
two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five rachel how's the
family how's everybody how we doing
we're doing good yeah i'm trying to
think yeah we
our kids are in school so i feel like
that changes the game i know i'm not
everyone around the country right now
so i still think about all you moms that
are having those computers up and
doing online school and the dads that
are making home offices in there
that's right that's right yes so laundry
room so when the kids are
in school it's a great thing it's a
whole whole different world
so we're doing great that's awesome we
have awesome teachers
awesome teachers but uh but no yeah it's
it's great winston are doing well
talking about marriage because tonight's
is the biggest thing this is
the money in marriage events which i'm
so excited about
all right so tell everybody what's going
on this evening yeah so john and i will
be hosting
i say hosting teaching talking hanging
out
yeah kind of like a hangout i know we
want to make it's going to be fun you
guys that was like john and i's
number one goal about tonight we want
you we we have a lot of fun we have
things we want to say we have an
important message that
to talk about you know how do you how do
you get united with your spouse when it
comes to money
and if you are how do you elevate that
like how do you really dig in
how do you have these vulnerable great
conversations
on you know like we're gonna talk about
some really great rich stuff
but also but also it's gonna be really
fun i feel like the last thing on earth
i want
is to sit down on a couch with my wife
hold hands turn on the tv and have
somebody just
lecture me for two hours right that just
seems like the worst
possible thing best valentine's evening
the least
romantic the last thing i need is
something else to make my life less
romantic
i'm already working from home right
parents
all over the place kids i don't want to
sit there for two hours that's me
lecture me so we've set this thing up
it's gonna be a blast
and our friends george and courtney are
gonna be there too it's just gonna be a
a good time it's gonna be a fun evening
and we're getting to some topics that
ramsay has not traditionally gotten into
right
we're going to be talking about is
forging the way
is that a phrase that's not super a good
way to say that but
it will kind of we're going to be
talking about our
romance man our intimacy man our how we
are communicating with one another
when things have gotten hard this last
year things were hard before this year
that's just exposed but was already hard
and so we're not going to flinch away
from any of the challenging
conversations we're going to take live
q a during the show so please check it
out shy
john dolone is really shy if you haven't
felt that and so
he's going to kind of tip toe around
some subjects that's like you haven't
been in all these meetings rachel
for the last year i've had to i've been
working it with
other therapists or with professors or
with other crisis people for so long
that it's not weird to be like oh i'm so
sorry
tell me about your sex life how are
things going and when we're having these
conversations here
is everyone's eyes bug out it's like 401
401 401 right so
401k 41k 401ks right so we are in new
territory but those are real questions
that people struggling with oh yes
well what's funny in my line of work if
someone asks me a money question like
outside of office
stuff they're like well you know
everything about doing this i'm like
okay well how much do you guys make
right and like what and i'm like oh
sorry yeah people don't talk about yeah
you don't talk about that
think about it that's exactly i love
that too so funny so funny
yeah i don't talk to my friends about
how much uh they make that's a great
have you thought about that no but and i
and i don't say it obviously to like no
just automatically yeah i'm like well
how much do you make how much debt you
have
i love it so anyway go to daveramsey.com
events get your tickets we can't wait to
see you there
we have exceeded they gave us this okay
here's here's our goal right here's what
we want to have
sweet john and rachel i wonder how many
people
so we they if they set a goal that was
like realistic and
you're way past that goal so there's
please join us daveramsey.com events
make a dinner tonight
um whoever doesn't usually cook you make
the dinner
and then you'll sit down get the kids to
bed early you know what i'm even giving
you permission
put them on a screen in another room
just have them go away
we start at seven o'clock and just take
this time to be
with y'all two together you and your
spouse be there together and um
enjoy each other enjoy some new content
and have some laughs along the way
all right so let's grab one call here
let's go to chris in boston chris what's
going on
hey guys it's good to speak with you um
i've got
a money question for rachel and a higher
ed question for dr john
all right bring it um all right so money
questions first i'm in baby step
two uh i've been doing it for about two
years and i've got about three more
years to go
uh 163 000 worth of student loans
plus a motorcycle and a car but um
yeah everything's paid off except for my
student loans um i've got
90 000 left to go so i've paid off wow
grand in the last two years way to go
man great job chris
thank you so as i was reading the total
money makeover a month or two ago
i came across a sentence that that made
me question whether or not i should
be investing um i i believe dave wrote
that if it's going to be a longer baby
step too you might want to do small
investments while you're doing it
because if it's going to take me close
to three years
to finish paying everything off i'll be
32 years old and all
have is you know three thousand dollars
in a roth ira
whereas if i invest 200 a month
for the next three years it'll only push
my payoff date by maybe three months and
i'll have at least a whole another
year's worth of investment
in that roth ira i want to know what you
think yeah so i hear that
and that mathematically is all correct
but there's this visceral emotional
sacrifice that i want you to have which
i feel like you have it because you've
already paid
off so much student loan debt already
but yes i
our rule of thumb black and white answer
here is pause investing and
everything goes toward the debt and that
that's our answer french all the time so
even that sentence i would have to even
go back because honestly i don't even
remember him saying that
um but i mean i was on page like 128.
128. well look i'll look it up
i'll be talking to goodwill hunting in
boston that's awesome i know
um but no and you're still young chris i
mean like
maybe we tilt the conversation if you're
65
and you have no retirement or anything
but even but even then
my advice would be no you want to get
this debt out of your life and so
chris you have time i know it doesn't
feel like it because you think oh
i'm going to be 32. i'm going to be so
old you're not you're not
all right so what's your oh good and the
amount that oh yeah we'll run out of
time go you sure okay what's your higher
ed christian chris
all right so once my debt's all gone um
i plan to cash flow
a degree a master's degree at least in
psychology and my side hustle is that i
coach
uh two swim teams and you know there's a
huge need for counseling for our kids
and most of them don't have access to it
so my bachelor's degree is in psychology
yeah um and i didn't know if you knew
anything about the field of performance
psychology or if maybe just a
master's in counseling would be
sufficient
but yeah i i think i think i would start
with a master's in counseling
and you when you move into those type of
performance psychology
or child psychology that's when you're
getting a clinical degree which is
at the doctorate level i think you are
great to go in
and get a master's in counseling you
have that experience working with kids
in that coaching area so it's going to
be a natural link there
and then you can do continuing education
on the back end to get some specific
things about working with kids in sports
but yeah get that masters in counseling
we need more people working in mental
health who
love their neighbors you're the guy man
thank you so much
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm dr john
dolone joined with best-selling author
and
good human being rachel cruz i probably
should stop calling you a good human
being
i know i like the title it makes me feel
like she was texting winston during the
break saying i'm a good human being i'm
a good human being that's right
all right so let's go to blinds.com find
out for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
all right today's question comes from
lindsay in georgia this is a big one
i cannot wait to hear what you have to
say about this drone i'm the sole earner
mom of three and three step kids my
income ranges from a hundred thousand to
two hundred thousand we've paid off
two hundred thousand dollars of our
initial three hundred and eighty
thousand dollars of debt in the past
three years
amazing my husband is a stay-at-home dad
and dude due to covid
and thinks that we should be spending
more money despite getting
200 a week i pay his child support and
his tuition he is a good roommate but a
terrible husband he has withheld all
affection
in the past years and prioritizes
netflix over me
i can withhold spending can i withhold
spending money
until he agrees to work on our marriage
we had counseling
but he would not follow up i'm so
exhausted lonely and depressed
i resent feeling i am good enough to
work
60 hours a week to support him but not
good enough to be
loved oh man
that's it's a lot there that's about a
year's worth of work here
there so to answer there's one question
in here
which is can i withhold spending money
until he agrees to work on our marriage
the answer is no no anybody who starts
who gets into the business of
withholding whether that's
i'm withholding affection intimacy i'm
withholding
um information i've got secrets
right i'm withholding um fears
i'm withholding money that that's that's
like i said even a red flag that's like
this giant neon sign
right yeah this feels like resentment
and this feels like this relationship
it actually feels like this relationship
is over and like you mentioned it we're
roommates now
he's got a good deal i got a good deal
and
i'm just exhausted lonely and the good
deal on the roommate stuff is run out
right um i don't think this is a money
question at all
no so let me just let me go high level
money and then i want you to dig into
this
because i i am curious all of your
thoughts so just a couple of things
lindsay
and again this is all the symptom of a
bigger problem so what i'm about to say
is not going to solve your life
here but even saying his child support
his tuition it it seems like you know i
i give him 200 a week you guys are not a
team
like it is a his and her viewpoint
and a little bit of it sounds like
you're being his mom that's exactly
right and
nobody wants to be nobody wants to have
a romantic relationship with their mom
right i wish there was another way to
say that
but he's being mothered right and
he's acting like a five-year-old who
needs a mom right and so now you get in
this weird dance because he needs to he
needs to
to buck up too like this isn't all your
fault lindsay
we're not picking on you but you do have
to realize
even the language you use shows where
you guys are at in the marriage even
just in the question which is
fascinating okay
so it becomes a dance right it becomes
i feel like she's always telling me what
to do she's acting like my mom
and then that shuts off all desire right
which then leads to i'm just gonna
retreat
and hide in front of netflix and
complain about not being able to go out
with my friends
which then he's acting like a
five-year-old and then she has to right
somebody has to say stop somebody's
gotta just
as terry reel says you got to turn and
stare the forest fire down
you got to look at both of you've got
stuff in your past that y'all got to
deal with both of you got six kids in
this house
um you make great money there's a part
of me that believes you think you're
better than him because he you make that
kind of money there's part of me that
thinks he
feels like he's a loser because there's
so much here
and at the end of the day you said it
best i'm so exhausted
lonely and depressed rachel i've heard
that those three words
over and over and over this this season
right
if your partner will not go to
counseling with you
if your husband or wife girlfriend
boyfriend won't go
you're left with one option and that is
to control what you can control and that
is to work
on you so you've got to go right
if if you both had the flu that's
probably not a good if you both had
strep throat and you go fill up both
prescriptions and he won't take his
medicine
that doesn't mean you don't take yours
in fact that means you've got to take
yours right because somebody's got to be
well
that's good yeah so spend the time the
money the energy
to get refilled it's not happening here
my hope is
my hope for this marriage is that when
she starts working through the
her challenges which are bigger than him
bigger than this mess
that she will get some new skills and
some new tools that will give her some
clarity on her next path
and hopefully will give her some clarity
on how to engage him
a little bit differently that he might
be able to hear it she might
have peace in her heart right she may be
able to start acting outside of this
marriage
and um that sounded weird not act
outside the marriage but start
here yeah start having like right you're
just gonna start exercising again start
taking care of yourself start having
friends and community members go get
re-engaged with a local church or local
community groups or whatever that looks
like
and my hope is that your husband will
see that and say i want that
right blaming and criticizing and
yelling never have solved a problem in a
marriage
right and i love that control which you
can control because i think that's one
of the most frustrating things
in life we talked about that you know
even last hour but it's like yeah if you
you yeah you don't have an option right
you're not gonna just like absolutely
drag him you can't physically drag him
and even if you did
and set him in a room with a counselor
he's not gonna do any good right he's
not gonna he
he he chooses to hear it or not so so
being able to control what you can
control but lindsay i'm so sorry
this is a story for a lot of couples out
there are in this and that's one thing
i'm excited about our event tonight to
hopefully bring
a level of clarity and tools to people
um because it's tough but thanks lindsay
thanks for your question all right let's
go to
sean in baton rouge louisiana
what's up sean how we doing hey guys
how's it going uh
doing okay yeah we're doing great
good good uh my question is uh my wife
and i
are gonna be first time home buyers and
we're working with a credit uh company
to to get our credit up to where
we need to be to get approved for a loan
and
we had a deadline of april 1st and it
just seems like the
credit company is uh kind of dragging
their feet a little bit
and i'm wondering on paying certain
debts off if there is a
a faster way to go about getting our
credit scores up to where we need them
to be
how do we go about doing that sean are
you are you working your way out of debt
currently
uh yes it's not much that it's under
eight thousand dollars okay and like
have you been
have you been working the plan have you
been getting out of debt in the last you
know
18 to 24 months paying off debt
uh within about the past 12 12 months
okay so
here's the deal with the credit score
your credit score mathematically is made
up on how you interact with debt
so the fact that you guys have stopped
going into debt and you're paying
off debt your credit score is going to
lower that's what's going to happen
now it will be basically to the point
that it's it's not a zero but it gets to
this point where it's
they can't calculate it anymore after
about 18 to 24 months
which is about enough time that i want
you guys not buying a house right now
i want you to pay off that eight
thousand dollars and get a fully funded
emergency fund
before you go and purchase a home so so
my first rule of thumb sean is i don't
think you guys are in a place
financially where i would advise
to even be a homeowner i would continue
to stay where you are
um or rent for the time being
okay that's what we're doing now we've
been running for four years yep
and and i would i'm close man and it's
frustrating i know it is
but i would i because what happens is
when you still have this eight thousand
dollar debt over you
you have no savings you go move into a
home and
60 days in your heating and air brakes
and you're like well what do we do we
have no money i guess we gotta go take
on you know take out
debt to repair that or if it's on a well
if they're like right and and the well
goes bad we gotta
we gotta we gotta get water so we gotta
take out that you know and so it ends up
being a curse
in your life versus a blessing
and i want a home because home ownership
is so expensive and i know it's
frustrating to rent i know it feels like
it's just money
going down the drain but it's not you
guys are being wise you're being wise
i promise stay in it until you're out of
debt and you have that fully funded
emergency fund
so my wife and i bought a house back in
august
inspected great we even had some
exchange with the homeowners awesome and
within the last four or five months
new roof new driveway new right it just
happens right it just is never gonna be
us
it is gonna be us right so i love that
so hard to rent we did it we did it we
did it
just hang in there you're so close
you're so close sean do it the right way
man
and that way you can sleep with peace
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsay to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
taking your calls on your life and your
money
i'm john delonie joined here with rachel
cruz
let's go to silas in munich indiana
silas what's going on man how can i help
hey hla john thanks so much for taking
my question you got it
uh so i just got engaged back uh in this
previous december
nice congratulations hold on rachel says
you said that nice nah well i thought
december
a holiday engagement oh yeah it all went
through my head was it a uh
christmas engagement engagement yeah it
was the day after christmas actually
oh day after well played man she's nice
that's where that came from
she know it was coming uh she
kind of i mean we talked about it
obviously but no she was very surprised
but it was that when i did it was when i
did it way to go
so fun all right i'll leave you alone go
for it so what's up man
um well so like i said just got engaged
and we're planning on getting married uh
in the end of august okay uh so i'm
finishing up my last semester
of my undergrad um and i i don't have
any debt so i myself am currently on
baby step four
um my fiance graduated last may
um so she's been working for a year and
she did have a considerable amount of
student debt and so she's been working
to pay that off
as quickly as possible um and and she's
really been doing a great job i mean
she's
it's been amazing to me honestly how
much she's paid off during that time
even
and we both have enough money saved up
right now to
to fully pay for pay cash for our
wedding
in august my question is uh once we got
engaged and we had set a wedding date i
had stopped my own investing
and started kind of setting that money
aside in my savings so that once we get
married
i can take that chunk of cash as well as
my fully funded emergency fund
and put all that money towards the debt
since at that point i'd be on baby step
two
with her am i am i thinking through that
correctly am i doing the right thing or
should i
still be investing myself and and
be on baby step four right up until uh
we get married um i mean because you're
so young silas because of your age
uh a few months is it going to make or
break it honestly
um on the investing side so honestly i
think you did a great i think that's a
great job the only
word of caution for anyone else
listening is
you know you're you you go through the
process of stopping your investing
stopping your 401k
all of that which takes paperwork i mean
it's a it's a process
and then if something happens and the
wedding doesn't go into effect then you
have lost those months
of investing but obviously you go into
an engagement
believing that this is it right
wedding's gonna happen so
so i'm sure you know i'm sure
everything's gonna be fine so the fact
that you
paused it i'm totally great with and
you're gonna have
a pile of cash that emergency fund that
you do have and so you're exactly right
you'll take all of that and you guys
will together
start back on baby step two and start
working out so i'm curious how much debt
does will she have in august
and how much do you have saved up like
how much of a debt
yeah so she when she graduate graduated
she had probably
around 45 000 and
um in august she'll probably be down to
somewhere between 15 and 20 000. awesome
she killed it you're right
yeah she's been doing great um and then
i
by that time and with working this
summer after i graduate
i'd say i could probably have around um
10 saved up maybe a little less it's
awesome
wow that i mean that's a huge huge head
start not many married couples get
married and only have about
five or ten thousand dollars of debt oh
that's incredible you guys will knock it
out you're both motivated
i think it's just i think it's fantastic
so i think you're doing exactly what you
should be doing so great job
silas one one trap to watch out for
yeah what is something that she is
bringing to this
relationship that you would say i'm so
thankful she's breaking this i'm gonna
have to work on this for the next 2 5 10
15
20 years uh
i mean i think first of all she helps me
my walk with christ she encourages me to
be kind
encourages me to love others well um she
really pushes me to to grow so that i
can lead
our marriage well and so just from that
standpoint the encouragement she gives
me encouragement she gives me to
look to christ be dependent on him
i mean that's that's worth very cool so
sometimes when folks are are getting
married one of you
is sitting there debt-free with an
emergency fund the other one's
got debt it's easy to feel
like i'm giving all this stuff up or i'm
the one making these concessions
i'm gonna go ahead and help bail us out
so we can start on a firm footage
she feels bad she comes in feeling
guilty right um
came in and immediately hooked a weight
to us right right and so
i want you to go in with that attitude
i'm not saying you are i'm using you as
an example for
millions of couples across the country
you know that she's bringing things too
right um to that are so extraordinary to
this that
you are going to learn and grow from and
so it's letting her know all of the time
we're all in this together right this is
our show this is our dance we're doing
this together
you've got this i've got that we're
going to be figuring out this is and
that's for the rest of our marriage
right yep
and um five years ten years me and
sheila just had one
uh that came up a few weeks ago
i've been with her almost a quarter of a
century and i looked at her and said i
don't think i know you anymore right
they all keep coming up silas
and so good for you make sure that she
feels like she is the
man she is the rock star in your world
and that she's not coming into this
marriage um dragging things down all
right let's go to leah in orlando hey
leah what's going
where are you there you are leah hey how
are you doing i'm i'm right here
thank you both i'm excited to be on the
show and to get some
advice i have kind of a mixed question
i am single and i'm 27 and
my plan was to buy a home in
october but life happens
and i met a wonderful man and he
is very special to me and um have a
great relationship
it's been about a year and
so i'm stuck you know i've got the money
saved i've got 20
down i've got the closing costs i've got
you know everything's going great and
i'm just trying to decide
whether or not i should continue with my
you know dream of buying a home or
whether or not i
should hold off and see what happens
over the next year
oh that's a good question have you guys
had any discussions lee are you guys in
the same city number one are you both in
the same part of orlando
we are about an hour apart from each
other he bought a home
about six months before we met and so he
does have a
home himself okay have you guys had any
of these discussions about where the
relationship's going
where if you if you have where you guys
want to be dtr that's what the kids call
it right
have you all had the dtr um yes we we do
have
you know we have had that discussion um
i like i can't
say that you know things are moving
quickly we're very strong
christians and and um we're
both in our you know um you know middle
to late
you know 20s and so we we do see a
future
together and um i could see us
getting married maybe in 20
22 2023 and so i
wouldn't think i would hope not any
later than 2023.
okay well i mean gosh
whenever there's a big life change that
is coming it's on the horizon it may not
be set in stone
but you know hey i'm going to shift
careers as an example and i know i'm
probably going to move closer to the
city or
man i want to do you know i want to be
closer to family when i have kids and we
want to start a family soon like you you
kind of know it's not it's a little bit
ambiguous but you know it's coming
i probably would pause because i would
love for you i love i would love a home
to be
at least a five-year gig for the most
part when you go and buy a home um three
to five years and so
i would hate for yeah you to go through
that buy
and then you guys decide to sell and all
that you could and it's not the end of
the world yet by any means you're doing
it by the book
but if you do want to pause for six
months and rent and kind of just see how
it flushes out
i i don't think that's a bad thing i
always like to look at the other side of
the risk
which is what happens if you don't and
really if you keep saving money
and you wait six months or eight months
and then you realize this isn't the
right relationship then your down
payment's 25
that's right you've saved up not you
don't lost anything except eight or nine
months and you're heartbroken
and then you can go buy a house and so
you're not off it's the risk on the
other side
feels greater to me so i'm with you
rachel i'd wait hang in there
hopefully he's the one hey hurry up dude
make it happen
quit waiting around 20 21. leah's
awesome
pull the trigger
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to michael
in kansas city missouri michael what's
going on
[Music]
um what are your previous callers
um i had student loan debt my wife was
able to graduate debt free
and we're able to pay for our master's
degrees
cash um you know me every single
question is
um you're just getting this money
hey michael hey michael i talked
directly into your phone man okay
there you go brother perfect okay um
i'm kind of opposite of the previous
caller um i had
student loan debt through from my
undergrad my wife graduated debt-free
we've paid for our master's degrees with
cash
but my question is i've got about nine
thousand dollars left
and through the stimulus money coming in
and having a child in 2020 with the
child tax credit on our new tax return
do i wait and see what the president
does or do i go ahead and pay it off
pay it off paid off today pay it off
today yeah yep yeah if we
wait around to see what bill is going to
pass through what
house in congress will be waiting a
long time and so to be able to control
which
what you can control it's kind of like
the theme i feel like of the show today
uh and it's this don't put your future
in your destiny in washington dc's hands
so i would 1000 be paying it off michael
it's
for me it's it's a two-part thing number
one um i got to see what rachel's
talking about ringside i worked with
some extraordinary
i'm talking about brilliant high
character wonderful
young men and women who were in law
school who intentionally
chose to go do public service work
instead of going to big fancy firms
where they were going to have
big fancy salaries they chose to go do
this work because they wanted to serve
their communities
and because if they did that work it
which is hard grueling work for a decade
the government said we're going to come
in and wipe those loans away and then
when they got to year 8 and nine
that went away and so they had
sacrificed not only
their direction in law school which if
you know anything about law school it's
just such a trajectory right it's hard
to circle back and do something
different x number of years down the
road
but man they had sacrificed five to
seven years of
major earning potential because they
were
they were given this promise right and
so there's that i think i think rachel's
super wise
here's the other thing there is
something in
i don't share this with everybody so i'm
just going to tell you what's in my
heart
when i took out student loans and i had
six figures man my wife and i had six
degrees between us we
um and then i went and got another one
that the school paid for but i i
six degrees between us we had six
figures in student loans it was hard
i didn't realize on some of these loans
i took out what i was signed
all that stuff i was not an educated
consumer when it came to that but at the
end of the day i signed my name to a
piece of paper
that said if you will help me get
through college for this money
i will pay you back and i have a
it's an it became an ethical issue for
me that i was working good jobs i had
money
now this isn't everybody this i was in a
fortunate position but i had jobs where
i had this money here and if i waited on
somebody to come in and pay for it
which is my tax dollars anyway all of
our tax dollars
i struggled with that personally so
you're in a situation where you're
holding money in your hand right now
i think that in my estimation if you've
got that money the right thing to do
is to go ahead and pay that off now not
everybody shares that ethical deal
that's just me but that's just me
talking to you
michael person to person here but the
broader conversation as rachel's talking
about is
yeah man you don't ever want to wait on
those things to make their ways
through washington yeah yeah and
depending on you know
getting into the we don't have to go
down this rabbit hole but
the student loan program has
really screwed up a lot of people's
lives now did they make the intentional
decision to go get into those loans
absolutely but the whole program is so
frustrating to me on that level that i'm
like i wish it just almost
it just didn't even exist right that we
like went the old school way of of what
it looks like to go to school
debt-free um so when i hear the word
relief
there is a part of me that i'm like yeah
i do i want relief for people
yeah they had no idea what was they were
signed up for yeah
yeah like you you kind of like they just
got screwed in it even though i know
they signed their name to it but man
so there is something that i'm like i
don't know how it would be done or what
would be done or
what that looks like because it probably
you know we're not gonna get into the
politics of it but
i would love a level of relief for
people right at some level
whatever that looks like but i'm not
gonna wait on washington just to deliver
it so let's
let's get to work because your point two
if you got it if you got it you
have it yes yes you got it you got it um
another thing is i've heard some of
these
some of these variants of the relief
bill have different um
things attached to them you're going to
owe us this much community service
you're going to owe us as much stuff
which i love i love some skin in the
game on that right i think that's good
but at the same time michael it goes
back to an earlier caller we had or um
somebody here in the lobby when you take
something from somebody
and they attach strings to that gift
you're beholden to them right
so man good for you i appreciate that
question it's a good question i know
that
i can't tell you how many times we get
that call people are all over the
country or wrestling with do i wait what
do i do do i just stop paying on that
because there's no interest now and some
of it may go away later
um i just want to say keep going if you
can and i hope we can get this thing
untangled it's just a mess seven ways to
sunday
um let's see here let's go to stephanie
in bloomington indiana stephanie what's
going on
hi um so i'm like 25 000
in debt okay um and i i it doesn't quite
sound like a lot to you guys compared to
other people
hey listen listen listen any amount any
amount stephanie is
oh there's folks at 5 000 might as well
be a million bucks so 25 grand is 25
grand
okay okay fair um so i
i want to start like the baby steps or
whatever i've been listening
to the show like every single day so i'm
like okay it's starting to like click
with me but i need a like a boost
on how to like go um i have
like the 25 000 in debt and i make about
33 000 a year um
what do you do for a living i have like
a um i work at a farm
yeah so um yeah i just don't know where
to start
yeah i don't know i don't know how to
call the right place
it's a great question i don't know how
to start a savings when i have credit
cards and stuff to be paying off
basically for sure well your first step
what you're going to want to do
is to get on a really tight
budget stephanie so i want you to we're
going to actually give you
we'll give you a a membership to ramsey
plus so kelly will pick up and give you
that
because this is our subscription that
you can get in we have the baby steps
tracker
ramsey plus or everyday every dollar
plus
uh in there that's going to help you all
the financial piece videos
yes fpu's in there so take all the
courses all of that but
every dollar the app is going to be your
friend stephanie this is really the
starting point because for the first
time in your life you're saying hey i
actually want to control my money
versus my money controlling me hey i
actually want to step into this
change what i've been doing which is
going to be hard stephanie this is not
going to be easy okay you're going to
get to point so you have to say no to
yourself
you're going to get points to say oh i
don't really want to do this there's
going to be times it's going to be very
very hard
but the key here is understanding change
is hard if you kept doing your normal
thing that's comfortable
you're going to keep getting the exact
same results that you've been getting
and you don't want to so
in order to make a change you're going
to feel that that tension
so just on the so when you when that
happens you'd be like oh rachel rachel
told me it's
this is it this is the friction i'm
feeling you're gonna feel it
um so understand that emotionally but
then yes doing the budget that's gonna
be your best friend and it's your income
minus all of your expenses equals zero
but that's going to include some giving
and saving because your first
goal after doing your budget is to get a
thousand dollars
and that's going to be your starter
emergency fund so that means stephanie
you're probably you're not going
shopping
you're not going on vacation you're not
going to eat you're not doing any of
that you're not spending any extra money
you're getting you're doing everything
you can you're working extra so you're
going to bump up that thirty three
thousand dollars you're gonna work at
night
and you're gonna do whatever you can to
bring in more money and cut expenses at
the same time to get that thousand
dollars
and then you're going to start working
your way out of debt so that 25 000
stephanie of debt what what is that uh
what
what kind of debt does that make up so i
have
my car that's a little over 16 000
and i have a total of credit cards
that's like 9.40
okay um and then i have a five thousand
dollar loan out
that i had gotten that was i thought was
gonna get me out of my old debt but it
just put me more in debt that's right
girl don't depend on anyone else to get
you out of debt you learn the hard way
so i mean i would even look at selling
the car stephanie paying off that 5000
first
and then moving up to that 9 400 by
sacrificing that lifestyle so
you can do it stephanie you can do it it
feels like a lot but now you're on the
front end of a fun adventure man it's
gonna be good
hey another hour in the books thanks to
kelly thanks to james
rachel thank you everybody be kind to
one another
we'll be back soon this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i am dr john dolone
joined here by best selling author and
good friend rachel cruz and we are
taking your calls on your relationships
on your money
on that upcoming wedding on what to do
in the baby steps we're taking your
calls on life
and money triple eight eight two five
five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
and rachel we've said it every segment
gotta say it one more time at least
tonight is the big money and marriage
event that's right
you and i are going to have an adventure
down in the tv studios here we're going
to beam it
to many more thousands of families that
we thought right
all over the country tell them all about
the event yes we're so excited about
this you guys it's our money and
marriage events
on valentine's weekend that was on
purpose
the love in your marriage we're going to
talk about
tonight but oh really how what does it
look like what does it look like to have
a better marriage and i think what's
interesting is where we are right now in
history for some people
it's a struggle it's a struggle
financially it's a struggle in their
marriage
like they are just having the worst year
of their life right
people have said uh and on the other
extreme some people have said oh no my
business has been booming financially
we're doing great or
my marriage no we've wanted we've wanted
to spend more time together now we're
not traveling for work and we get to be
home and it's what we really wanted like
so it's all it's this extreme when it
comes to these two subjects of money and
marriage so i love
that right now not only is it
valentine's weekend but we're diving
into it
in this world of 2021 and the craziness
that we went through in 2020
to really get no matter where you are on
the spectrum to get you to a place where
you know each other deeper you love each
other
better all of it and working on the same
page when it comes to your money so
one of the things i've i've heard we get
the the bell curve right we get the
way outside here the long tail here the
long tail here my marriage is better
than it's ever ever been we had to
figure some stuff out this year
and then with the politics and the
election
and coveted response all the stuff we've
got folks over here going
i don't know who you are right i have no
idea who i married right
yeah i kind of knew i just never asked
and now we super know
and then you've got millions of people
in the middle rachel who
man they've actually become really great
co-workers they've become
they've turned their home their work
from home their home school from home
into a well-oiled machine they don't
like it it's not optimal but they
figured it out they become great
roommates
but man they've lost that desire right
that spark like at the end of the night
dude i'm going to bed like i've seen you
all day
we're good high five good night right
and there's the other side of it right
which is
folks still figuring out the chaos of
that home right so wherever you happen
to be tonight is for you we're giving
you some actual real tools
that you can put into practice tomorrow
yes right that you can wake up tomorrow
yeah and yeah we said it earlier but
it's true yeah you're not gonna just sit
there
be bored the last thing i want right now
dragged you to
watch this for an hour and a half and
you thought man we could be watching
yellowstone but nope
here we are john rachel sitting on a
chair lecturing us it's not gonna be
like that at all it's gonna be super fun
we have fun man
so come hang out to us go to
daveramsey.com to get your tickets
uh dave ramsey.com shows get your
tickets
and we hope to see you there it's gonna
be a good time and if you're in ramsey
plus
remember it's really good for free so
log in tonight and your amazon
membership and you can stream it for
free
if you've been thinking about doing the
ramsey plus free trial you can get
online get the ramsey
plus free trial and get this event
tonight for free too so
there's a bunch of ways to watch but we
hope to see you there this evening
let's kick it out to christine in new
zealand hey christine what's going on
uh good thanks how are you guys super
what's going on new zealand
christine what time is it there um
it's 10 10 uh a.m
okay very nice okay what's your question
for us
um we're currently on baby steps three
but looking forward to
our next step which potentially might be
baby step 3b
but we've got a unique situation in um
where we work
we live on a site and that is for
free um and we plan to have this job
for you know the next 10 to 15 years
so just wondering whether we do babysit
3b
or move on to four
so you are yeah you're in a yeah that is
a unique position
because my so i kind of have i had two
answers flashed through my head as you
were speaking
one of them is i mean yeah if you're
going to be in that business
for 10 years you don't have to pay for
housing
start investing start looking you know
if your kids are going to get a higher
education outside of high school what
that looks like to save for
start working that and just be saving a
ton during that time which is amazing
but then the other part of me is like
man but i would love for you guys to
invest
and and have real estate i mean i paid
for home is a big part of people's
overall financial plan and how they win
long term is having that that's such a
big a big asset that i would hate for
you guys to completely miss out on so
for you guys is home ownership something
that you really you want
down the road eventually yeah yeah so i
guess
our um we're quite young still i'm 32 my
husband's 37
so when we potentially leave this job
which we really love so that's why we're
planning not to do anything anytime
soon but we don't want to walk away
with um you know like we'd love to walk
away with a pile of money that we've
saved that we can put a huge down
payment on something
yes um and yeah obviously
um have a smaller mortgage at that point
um
because just with our job and where we
live as well
we don't really want to own something
whilst we're in this job
um because we don't really want to be
you know landlords or anything like that
and we can't
really take time to get back to the
house
yeah for maintenance and stuff like that
no absolutely
yeah so i think yeah i think you're in a
great position just like you said i
would i would i would definitely start
investing
and then on the side no hey we have a
10-year goal that we want to put
50 down on a home or 75 or a hundred
percent
down whatever it is and to look out and
have that goal out there that you guys
are working at together and i think that
that's
i think that's perfect hey christine
what's your job what where do y'all work
um i don't think you have them over
there but we're motile managers
so we provide accommodation and part of
that is
um we have our house attached to the
reception so we're on site all the time
so i had a the opportunity for the last
gosh 15 years really to work with
colleges and universities and one of my
roles there was working with folks who
lived on campus
you know in the residence halls with
these students these are extraordinary
people
the work you do it never ends it's 3 65
24 7.
but they lived on campus and what i
would tell you is
i always had folks who had multi-year
plans i'm going to do this for
three to seven years and i'm gonna get
this there's an accelerated aging that
comes with living where you work
right and so it it begins you have a ten
year plan and then two years in it's
like what about a five year plan right
it's just a lot to ask of yourself when
there's something eventually
where you want your own yard you want to
have your own rules you don't want to
have people knocking on your door at 3 4
in the morning or whatever
just as a part of that gig okay so yeah
i'm with you there save up that money
and man being able to put a hundred
percent down on the house how cool yeah
but your quality of life in that type of
job is
it's a it's a big big deal that's a
great point so yeah stock that money
away
invest and then when you're ready to
transition out whether it's in two years
or 10
years and you'll be able to smile at the
mortgage office with what you're able to
put down
thanks for the call christine this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget
[Music]
[Applause]
often times people go years over paying
on insurance without even realizing it
that's why we recommend checking up on
your coverage with one of our endorsed
local providers or elp agents
elps are independent insurance agents
they're not like captive agents from the
insurance company you currently use who
can only
offer you one quote from that company
independent agents have the freedom to
shop around at multiple companies to get
you the best deal
and you know what most people who work
with an elp insurance agent save around
700 bucks a year that's 700
you were just giving away to an
insurance company
before you got better more affordable
coverage it's
free to have our agent shop around for
you so you've got nothing
to lose here nothing to lose it's free
text
insurance to 33789 insurance
text it to three three seven eight
nine all right let's go to tommy in
ventura california
tommy what's up man how are we doing
hey rachel and john thanks for taking my
call you got it brother what's going on
john i'm a huge fan of yours and when
you step down off that wagon i'm team
gummy candy all the way with you
hey listen i am in partnership with a
navy seal right now and i have to text
him
every day how many days i am sober from
sugar
otherwise i've got a hard hard workout
it's hard right now man
i am there are some things
oh yeah you're going to get me all
thinking about gummy candy man you're
getting me all screwed up
so what's up brother uh so i'm 29 years
old and i own a wedding venue with my
wife
a few years a few years ago we got hit
by the wildfires and we were forced to
shut down until we rebuilt
we're finishing up our permits right now
we should be open next year
and through our downtime we revamped our
business plan to being solely focused on
the venue to kind of being all-inclusive
to include the venue rentals food all
the way down to wedding planning
so we have a friend who is a part-time
wedding planner in the past
she has been vocal and clear that she
wants to work for us one day
in the past we were open to it but we
know now that we're not going to employ
her because she doesn't have the
experience we want
and in the past we've been burned from
hiring friends so we've just made a rule
that we're not going to hire friends but
we'll recommend them
we have not told her our plans for
expansion but we feel she should
we should let her know what's happening
in us hiring full-time planners and not
here through the grapevine
we want to be kind and compassionate to
her but also preserve the friendship
we know it's not going to be an easy
conversation and that there will be hurt
feelings
um but we want to still have that
friendship and we want to go about in
the wise way i want to see what you guys
have to say
man who are you dude every time
already pretty cool i think the
internets make me just sad about the
future
i get to talk to a tommy from ventura
man reminds me that there are
so many extraordinary people out there
um tommy here's the thing this is one of
those
conversations that um is like uh
it's gonna be hard and it's a blessing
at the same time
okay i would tell you the number one
thing that you and your wife need to do
going into it is have exactly what
you're gonna say
and it's gonna sound dorky but maybe
even go over it with each other
um write down what you want to say in
which you communicate one of the things
that people do when they talk to
loved ones in hard conversations is they
start babbling
and they start over communicating and
over apologizing and over
everything and then next thing you know
she's either hired or you've gone one
step too far
it's because you're not accountable
right you just say too much
and so keep it short keep it like
i mean your heart you're gonna be a
person of dignity you're gonna treat her
like a person a dignity which is awesome
the second thing i would do is really go
into it with an open heart knowing you
can't hold the outcome here
if she chooses to hate you guys that's
her choice not
it's not as a result that y'all did the
right thing for you and your family and
your business
okay and anytime you have these
vulnerable conversations
these truth-telling conversations are
never comfortable and this happens with
marriages this happens with
kids and their parents it happens with
um employees it happens all the time
the the if you got this skill of having
hard conversations
being short direct um you know the
the say it directly don't beat around
the bush no
we love you but we we're not going to be
able to employ you
at this time we've got this entire
vision we need someone with a lot of
experience you're not quite there yet
we're so grateful we love you as a
friend i know this is super hard for
everybody
we hope you'll still be our friend in
the in the future
man we'll love to use you if we can but
right now we're not going to bring you
on
and that's the end of the conversation
okay
do you guys recommend like an in-person
just like
informal like a breakfast lunch or what
would you say is the best way to do that
kelly and james are laughing at me
because i love having conversations over
breakfast
this is one it depends on the level of
your friendship this is one
that feels simple enough for me and
quick enough for me that i don't know
that i would
um it definitely definitely has to be in
person right definitely
to meet in person there but it could be
over coffee it could be a broader
conversation
i don't think it needs to this one feels
pretty pretty slow pretty quick unless
this is somebody that you are super
tight with
your kids play together y'all been
through the ringer together y'all went
to college together something like that
where it's going to be i'm going to go
over to your house and we're going to
have a conversation i've made a few of
those in my lifetime
that's great just not over text don't do
anything
over text right like i thought yeah and
man i'm grateful for your heart tommy
that's good rachel what do you think
yeah for sure and i would say yeah i
think you and your wife being on the
same page i know
conversations that winston and i have
had to be in together we know
we have a plan going in so no i don't
think that's cheesy at all john i think
that's
very very wise and such a great point
that people
babble that is me i will like go keep
keep going keep going keep going
oh my gosh is that too much and then all
of a sudden i've hired him yeah right
i've i i didn't hire him for this i
think you're great yeah that's right and
we're hiring a full-time nanny it's
gonna be you right or you end up saying
you
try to defend yourself so much you
insult somebody
that's right that's right that's right
you don't treat him with respect and
dignity and
just just your whole spirit about this
tommy is so good and
um it's a good reminder for me to always
remember who's the listener right who's
the who's the person receiving this
information that's right
right so good for you brother all right
let's go to jorge in detroit
michigan is it jorge or george brother
there's already how you guys doing all
right all right um good man what's going
on how can we help
i'm saying say my call first of all um
let's make some advice from you guys i
listened to dave ramsey show when you
guys
ever once in a while so i know you guys
are good solid advice
um at the moment i just kind of feel
trapped um i'm 29
i started a business a photography
business about three years ago
and the only reason i did that is
because i was kicked out of high school
in ninth grade
and i never went back i never got
another degrees or nothing
to be honest and i knew i had this
talent so i was just like why not help
why not go ahead and pursue it you know
so i started doing that and i'm to the
point where i'm doing pretty decent
whether this is growing i would like it
to be
um and now i'm to a point where i have
no degrees
but i'm an entrepreneur i own my own
business i've been in rooms with people
and i work with people who have all
these degrees
from harvard just fell into just you
name it
doctors and lawyers and everything i
have no idea
that i have no degrees and i'm going to
keep it that way there you go good for
you brother
yeah the only thing i was questioning
was this
should i even consider maybe going back
and getting that gd or getting any
degree at all or should i just keep
striving the way i'm doing it
and just see what i can do without it
that's my question to you guys
man rachel you mind if i hop in on this
go go john you're the you're there
so there's two a two-pronged answer to
this okay
tell me if i'm right or wrong here
number one
you're real real smart and
you probably lined up next to get if i
went and found 25 guys i bet you
would be confident that you would
outwork them is that correct oh
for sure for sure yeah and i bet you've
got a standard of excellence that rides
real high when you're dealing with
people's photographs you're dealing in
the business of people's memories and my
guess is your attention to detail and
excellence is high is that right
it is very correct yeah all right so
when it comes to
excellence perseverance hard work you've
got those three things
and you also have a demon in your soul
about getting kicked out of school in
ninth grade don't you
i do and there's something about
you walking into that room where you
know i am just
everybody in this room put their pants
on today i've got value just like
everybody in this room
but they told me back when i was 14
years old that i'm not good enough
am i right so you pretty much got it
yeah
all right so here's the thing you don't
need to go to school
to learn work ethic you don't need to go
to school brother to
learn how to grind and talk to different
people and learn all these soft social
skills
but if you're my best friend if you and
i were just hanging out and having a
drink on the back patio
i would tell you i want you to take that
14 year old boy go get that ged
for nobody else but for you nobody else
but for you
and there's some some kind of closure
some kind of healing that's going to
come from that do you need it
no but man would it launch you
yeah so mandy i want guys like you in my
community brother
it's so good i say go get that ged
and if you hey if you don't you're still
good just
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john deloney
with my good friend rachel cruz and
we're taking your calls on money
relationships and life triple eight
eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five rachel we got a lot
going on here
on the valentine's day extravaganzas huh
that's right valentine's day everyone
sunday don't forget it and one of the
big things
when it comes to your money to make
progress is to be on the same page
with your spouse you have to learn to
work together as a team
reach your goals as a team and really
see yourself as one
and to help to get on the same page we
have gathered some of our best-selling
books budgeting tools
and bundles for couples and one big sale
you can save up to
83 on gifts that's going to help you
reach your financial goals so this is
the last
week for the sale do not miss it and
don't miss again our money marriage live
stream which is happening tonight you
can still get tickets
it's myself rachel cruz and dr john
zalone will walk you through how to have
a fun date night and have great
conversations
when it comes to your money so you can
visit daveramsey.com
backslash store to get your live stream
tickets and
the valentine's day's gifts to help you
build a bright
future with your spouse and that sale
ends february 14th so sunday
so you've been having this these
conversations with couples for
years and years and years long before i
was around
why is it so hard for couples to come
together around their money
when when i i off-handedly mentioned
something the other day about
having this a joint checking account and
you would have thought
oh you know what i mean it was just like
i was speaking
like a different language and um it
didn't occur to me that that was such a
radical notion
right so you've been talking to these
couples why is that so hard for people
to come together
i mean i think it's a couple of things i
think ultimately we're told this lie
out in our culture that yeah just
because you're married you still need to
be independent
you still can't fully depend on your
spouse you still
you still need to to have your thing to
make sure that you're okay in case
something happens like there's
there's all these kind of messages or
that you deserve to spend what you want
you make more money so go and do it like
there's like this division when it comes
to money and it feels different i don't
know tell me if i'm wrong but it feels
different than even parenting yeah but
it even feels different than like your
relationship with your in-laws
and like talking about boundaries like
around holidays all that feels
money still feels like it can be this
independent entity within marriage
and people believe that it's a it's a
tool so i know over the last 25 30 years
as we've still got a long way to go as a
country but as women have gained more
economic independence
it's shifted some conversations right
yes like it's
women are have more excess like more
accessibility more ability to move in
and out of
um hard conversation hard situations
but it feels like when like when i was
just thinking when you were saying this
when when couples are you're married but
you still need to make sure
you're going to be okay yes that's going
into a situation
but leaving the a crack in the door
right which we all know when you if you
do that relationally
right you're just setting it up for it
not to hold right yeah so
so i think we have been told that you
still you need to right you need to run
on these separate tracks so
what does that end up doing that ends up
literally ruining marriages
because you'll see that money like you
said it's just a tool
and so i talk about my new book but it's
true like so many life problems and
marriage problems masquerade themselves
as money problems
it's not really that you have a
budgeting problem with your spouse it's
that
you guys have no idea how to have
empathy with each other you have no idea
how to communicate like
it's other issues it's coming out as
money but it's
really some other things going on within
the marriage and it's like this
ban it's like oh so so people live these
separate lives because it's just easier
we got you like oh yeah it's just easier
if he has his and i have mine
and we will go 10 years just quote
unquote
not avoiding that big hard conversation
because it's quote unquote easier right
and then you end up in a your wreck's
coming either way right
you're gonna have to have a conversation
at some point that's right
so the avoidance of it people think that
they're doing a great job and like no
no no and so that's hard to i think
people are just
opposites you know so like winston and i
we from the beginning because we got
married so young
we have quote unquote you know been won
when it comes to our money
we budget together all that but still to
this day we just had this conversation
it was two mornings ago about a big
purchase i want to make
and i'm like oh okay we have the money
like can we just do it he's like man
he's like i just don't [ __ ] sold the
price tag babe he's like
because it's an experience so it goes
away after we do it
and he's like how many more things could
we buy like we're just opposite in how
we
how we want to even use money at times
right and it takes this
it's a give and take of me hearing and
understanding that
him hearing and understanding me getting
out of the place of
of neediness that i have in the purchase
his fear and what that really is right
so there's like all these root issues
when you can get to that and have a good
conversation then you can say hey we are
different but we love each other well
and serve each other well
and there may be a give and take on
certain months but but we make it work
so tell me if this analogy works i had
somebody or several people reach out and
say
i would never have a joint checking
account again i'm never going to be
unified in money because one time
i got hurt real real bad right somebody
my previous girlfriend a previous spouse
took advantage of me
i'm never doing it again previous
boyfriend took off with everything i
have i'm never doing it again
it's always gonna be separate tracks
from here on out and the analogy that
went into my head is
sometimes i've gone to a store and
bought an appliance
and i took it home and plugged it in and
it worked for like a month and then it
broke
does that mean i should never have a
refrigerator again right
it doesn't it just means that i gotta go
through a hard process to get that whole
thing out box it back up take it all the
way back get my money back
it doesn't mean that it's broken to suit
because you got hurt one time
that's right you got to grieve it and
what makes me sad too is those people
that make those absolute statements in
their minds
they go into another relationship
setting themselves up
and and that other person now is having
to
reap the reap the terrible results of
something that they didn't have anything
to do with
so they're they're absolutes yeah their
their their
attempt to protect themselves is
guaranteeing the next relationship isn't
going to be successful
yes and that they're having and that
poor other spouse or significant other
is paying the price for someone they
didn't even know
and they're like no and and then that
and instead of saying hey i'm going to
be vulnerable and this is going to be
hard
and scary and i got burned back yes but
i'm going to allow myself to open up
because that's going to be a
that's going to show trust yeah right
within the marriage i don't know you're
the psychologist well if you take if you
take the word vulnerability
a a synonym for it is exposed right yes
yes you are putting yourself in a
position that somebody could hurt you
and that is the unfortunately the only
way you can truly be loved
is to be to offer yourself up that way
yeah and if two people offer themselves
up that way then
you can come together if you hedge your
bets in a relationship man so that's
great wisdom i appreciate that i've been
i've been caught off guard by it and um
i love isn't it funny that's like the
one thing
if i post on social media i can say cut
up your credit cards
i hate student loans like i can i can
throw out these things but if i say join
your checking accounts
you would then come out right i ran over
someone's dog yeah and i
meant to and was like ha ha here i am in
my car
being this terrible person oh people get
it
but i can hear that it's scary right
that's right if you've been hurt if
you've got no model for it
that's right but i want people to get
beneath that and say man
if you're going to be with somebody if
you're going to pledge i'm going to be
with you forever that means you are all
in
all cards on the table you're not
joining you're checking out with some
dude you met at the bar
right right you're doing it with a sp
with the person you're married to that
you're committed to for life
go all in you go into that marriage
ceremony and say we are doing this for
life that's what marriage is when you go
all in
you could lose right but that's that's a
risk that's that's and that's the beauty
of it i love it all right let's go to
andrew in toronto
andrew what's going on man hey guys how
are you thank you for
taking my call it's awesome you bet man
what's up
uh so my question is that um my fiance
and i we
sat down we spoke about baby steps we
have just entered the
baby step number two very excited to you
know get the snowball debt rolling
but then now it just hit me that we have
a wedding to now
prepare for save for just i i kind of
got like a roadblock like what
would be this what would we what sorry
what would the steps be do we
stop with this with this baby step
number two save for the wedding
somehow do both just kind of want to get
your guys taken
so let's do this lucky for you andrew we
have a
marriage and planning expert in rachel
cruz right here
and also a baby step expert all in one
human being
after the break we'll come back and then
we will pick up from there
you are listening to the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
scripture of the day is second
corinthians 1 5 for as we share
abundantly in christ's sufferings
so through christ we share abundantly
comfort too
abraham lincoln says be sure to put your
feet in the right place
then stand firm
good ol abraham lincoln all right so
we're talking to andrew in toronto
andrew you are getting married
you are planning for a wedding and
you're in baby step two you're also
trying to pay off debt all at the same
time do i got that about right
yes yes sir that's it okay andrew how
much
how much will you guys be making
together combined income after you get
married
um 110 okay and how much debt will you
both have going into the marriage
uh that would be about probably sixty
sixty thousand
sixty thousand okay okay well so the
rule with baby step two is when you have
a big
life event coming up you know maybe
you're getting laid off
you know you'll be losing a job maybe
you are pregnant and expecting you have
a wedding coming up
there is a time and place to pause the
baby steps
and to save on the side for this event
that you know is coming up so that would
be the same for the wedding
um but for you guys i mean i and again
there's not a there's not a dollar
amount specifically or a percentage that
you guys need to save
i number one don't want you going into
debt for the wedding and then number two
you guys have
debt so knowing okay we're probably not
going to have this crazy
extraordinary massive expensive wedding
we're we're gonna do it as as well and
as
much as we can love it and it'd be
inexpensive
and being aware of the cost all of that
because what that's going to do
is it what you spend on the wedding and
then what you don't spend on the wedding
is going to affect how fast you guys pay
off this debt
so um so focusing yes i would i would
pause baby step two to answer your
questions save up a little bit for the
wedding
making sure that that's covered and then
you can press play on baby step two once
you have that amount of money or after
you guys get married but
um but and john you can speak to this
more and more but i'm like
the wedding is wonderful right and it's
every especially the the woman
in the relationship we you love it's
what you dream about it's your wedding
day
it's fantastic um but it's but it is a
day as wonderful and as celebratory it
is
it is a day and we just live in a
culture that we go insane
go insane for weddings so we're going to
talk about this uh on a previous show
and i'm glad you're here so let's do
this okay so help me
help me if i can remember help me figure
this out number one
i think that we as a culture
have stripped out all traditions
all ceremony all pageantry and i think
that's to
our detriment we have we go in
and we just mow down these wonderful but
small
older homes we knock down grandma's
house and we
look at it as how many tall and skinnies
can we shove into this square footage
right
and we take this home that will be here
for 300 years and we just knock it down
because we can get some more roi in that
way i think that's just a cultural thing
why are we still doing weddings let's
get rid of them so there's a part of me
that is
all about man weddings used to be a
big deal right a week long two weeks
they were celebrations right
there's that then the other side of it
is
people are spending 30 50 100 000
oh yeah plus on a day
a day and that sounds insane to me
right my my wedding was so great
so fun and i don't i know it wasn't that
right
so walk me through that balance between
the importance of the day
versus man we've kind of lost our mind a
little bit on the circus and the
ceremony of it all yeah i feel like i'm
talking to both sides of my mouth right
but no it's true but it's true it's a
balance and i think that that's the key
and i think knowing your motivation on
why you want
the kind of wedding you want is
important okay right like i
okay well i want the most beautiful
centerpiece i want all of this because i
want the great pictures i want people to
see it i want people to be impressed
like what's your motivation
to have these things or for it to look a
certain way and i bet if you stripped it
down to say okay
let's just say nobody sees the wedding
but you and your you and your
fiance
so you know many more people than you
know many more brides
than than i do you hang out with them
right let me say it this way hang out
that sounded weird all the brides all
the brides i hang out with you've had
more conversations about wedding in your
lifetime than i have how about that
um how much of a ceremony how much of
the the extravagance of a wedding is
so we can have those pictures
um probably a significant part
yeah and i think people because this is
how i feel even 11 years after marriage
you want people to have fun you want
people to come to your wedding and be
like that was a fun wedding and that's
how i am
i love that idea yeah man that was a fun
great wedding so like that would be the
pressure i put on myself today but yeah
your pictures
i mean whether it's the albums or what
you put online now like all of that
i mean yeah i mean i feel like that
that's a that's a big part of it
so i don't have a solution i i just i
like the conversation because i feel
like i'm knowing your motive your heart
your motivation on why
what's your why and do you have the
money and then here's the other talking
on both sides of our mouths
even if you have the money do you do
is that good use of yourself is it
necessary yeah you know where at the
point is it like a so is it a
is it a percentage of your net worth
maybe that's i don't you know whatever
it looks like but it's
it's an interesting conversation because
people can do it on these extremes
right and it's a whole industry i mean
they oh people are taking out loans
to go get a photo booth you know at the
reception right now
or you can just cram all your buddies in
the backyard and have a great old time
and at the same time yeah there's
something about that
legacy that big event that everybody
comes to
right right it's the centerpiece event
so i don't have any good answers
you all america i just was hoping rachel
could help me and
she cannot so all right let's go to
corey
in des moines iowa corey what's going on
brother how can we help
um so i uh with this cold temperatures
coming
we got uh essentially laid off for a
week and a half
i'm sorry no it's it's
uh we're doing okay but uh
how do you plan for that in baby step
two because
the thousand dollar emergency fund i
make uh
quite a bit of money uh low 200s
and losing a month
or a week and a half of pay
how do you plan for that outside of
baby step one um
because we're getting pretty well
intense on baby step two
but now we were in this
crisis of sorts and
is that something that you balance the
year
and save some money throughout the year
for this and how much would you save
being gazelle intense uh corey do you
know when the
when those times that you won't be
working and not getting a paycheck do
you know ahead of time kind of when
those are coming or do you know the day
of
how how much of a time frame do you have
so with the weather
right now we found out last friday
that we would not work this week okay
and then
monday and tuesday it's going to be cold
temperatures again
so as of right now uh we won't be
working until wednesday
okay so you're is it when you don't work
is it like a week at a time or
do you foresee like a month you'll be
out of work at any point
um or is it usually short-term usually
it's
it's short-term and i've been doing this
career for
20 years and this is only the second
time it's happened so it's rare
yeah yeah but i was i was kind of
unprepared and hopefully in a year
i won't have to worry about it sure but
um
yeah i i would be great people too
because because our goal for you
especially on baby step two is that you
cover your four walls so you have your
food your shelter utilities and
transportation that you have that
covered and i don't want you getting
behind on debt either
and so there's a level of your your um
standard of living that you have
having a budget no okay these are the
bills that we absolutely have to pay
and i'm not talking about clothing or
miscellaneous or out to eat like these
are
the things that absolutely have to be
paid and if you know okay we're probably
i
i'm not gonna have enough time to save
for those things
because i get a day or two days notice i
would be okay with you setting some
money aside knowing that i'm in an
industry that i won't get a paycheck for
a week
and knowing that that is a reality um
that's okay cory to do and to plan for
that now that's not to say
you know if you have a salary job out
there as a accountant
that's not me saying that okay you need
to save more than a thousand dollars on
baby step one because you have a
predictable income but when you are in
an industry like you said corey
that there's a chance you won't have the
money and that thousand dollars will not
cover your bills
putting some aside is okay corey how
long have you all been uh
uh you know what keep the keep it going
we just got ran up against the clock so
hey we want to encourage you in your
debt-free journey i want to thank james
childs and kelly daniel for
their superior production of today's
show i think bobby the engineer
rachel you got a future in this if
you'll keep working hard
it's going to be great john excited
about tonight money and marriage we'll
see at the money marriage event dave
ramsey.com to get your tickets
thank you for joining us be kind to one
another this has been the ramsey show
[Music]
you